good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster and today a super
league to say
football the words of the man in charge
of it but
will it really the lassie education
secretary gavin
williamson shortly as the prime minister
prepares for talks with the fa
and fans representatives today also
we'll hear from one of england's
greatest ever players david seaman of
arsenal
and england for his views on the super
league
and we're going to be talking to the
celebrity hairstylist nikki clark who's
working with police
to help hairdressers spot stars signs of
domestic abuse
amongst their customers it is tuesday
the 20th of april
vans united lead supporters shouted the
liverpool team bus as the new boss of
the super league
gives his first defense on camera
we're doing this to save football which
is in a critical moment
there's a lot of questions you know i
can only say my personal opinion i don't
like it and
you know hopefully it doesn't happen
climate crisis sky news understands the
uk plans to set a new
target to reduce emissions hospitals at
breaking point
new lockdown in delhi as india is put on
the uk's
travel red list where they're live
the world is watching protest accord
as the george floyd trial hears its
closing arguments
and looking for new leads the appeal to
find the owners of more than 80 stolen
dogs discovered at a traveller's site
warm in the sunshine today but it will
be cloudier across northern ireland and
scotland with some rain
as that spreads southwards tomorrow
it'll introduce some cooler air and some
frosty nights
well very good morning to you he says it
will save
football the words of the boss of the
super league who've spoken on camera for
the first time
since the news broke but is he right
the prime minister is preparing to host
a meeting with the fa the premier league
and fans representatives today
to try to stop football from tearing
itself apart over the proposals for a
european breakaway league of elite clubs
fans at last night's leeds liverpool
game showed their anger at whatever they
could
lead supporters shouting and chasing the
liverpool team bus
our sports correspondent martha kellner
reports
[Music]
a message from leeds united fans making
their feelings clear
[Music]
on the ground the sense of anger was
palpable
nothing has united supporters of all
clubs in shared outrage
quite as effectively as the european
super league
this is about fans this isn't about
which club you support this isn't about
being partisan there's plenty of time
for that in football but this is about
keeping fans at the heart of football
leeds united director victor alter with
this display of solidarity
inside the player's t-shirts made clear
they
too reject the idea of a league based on
money and marketability
rather than merit even rival manager
jurgen klopp and vice captain james
milner
whose club drove the breakaway are in
opposition
it's a tough one people are not happy
with with that i can understand that
but i cannot a lot more say about it to
be honest because we don't
we were not involved in any you know any
processes not the players not me
we didn't know about it i can only say
my personal opinion i don't like it and
you know hopefully it doesn't happen why
don't you like it what is it what is it
the reasons that everyone else has been
talking about over the last day
obviously it's been difficult for us
with
with
our only game we're trying to prepare on
the game
but i can only imagine what's been said
about it and
probably agree with most of it
today the executives of all 14 premier
league clubs excluded from the super
league
will meet to discuss how to respond to
the gauntlet thrown down by the rebel
clubs
and these are the billionaire owners of
those six clubs
manchester united manchester city
arsenal
tottenham hotspur liverpool and chelsea
we rarely hear from any of these men
but last night we did finally see at
least the new chairman of the super
league
also the president of real madrid who
has long agitated for a break away
we're doing this to save football which
is in a critical moment
a real madrid versus manchester game or
a barcelona vs milan
game are more attractive than a
manchester game against a more modest
team that takes part in the champions
league
because all countries take part
the important clubs in england italy and
spain must find a solution to a very bad
situation that football is going through
plans for the super league are still
sketchy and could yet be derailed by
legal challengers
the prime minister will also host talks
with fans representatives
and the fa today they believe they can
still stop the super league in its
tracks
martha kellner sky news
let's talk to the education secretary
gavin williamson morning to you look at
this meeting with the prime minister
today what do you think it could achieve
well what the prime minister wants to do
is to listen to fans listen to those
people who have a real interest in
football
and are passionate about football and
outline his
clear view that this is a super league
that must be stopped because it's just
simply not fair it's not right
football is rooted in the communities
and clubs have grown
up in and um you know it's there for the
fans it's there to be
uh you know part of that community and
this super league looks as if it would
really destroy that but also the key
core element of football which is
competition
because as we uh watch for premiership
it's not just a battle for the top
it's also a battle for survival at the
bottom and this
seems to have been dreamed up by money
men
as against uh something for football
fans and that's why
the prime minister is so opposed to it
and yeah yeah you will have heard in our
report though fiontino perez
saying that this is about saving
football
well in fairness he was bound to say
that wasn't he
and um what we are wanting to do is to
put the interests of
fans right at the heart of this but the
interests of
a whole uh game of football at the heart
of this and that's not something that
these proposals for a
european super league is doing uh it's
ignoring communities it's ignoring
uh the competition that exists in the
game of football
and that's why the culture secretary
yesterday in the house of commons
made it absolutely clear the steps that
the government is going to be taking
to ensure that uh this is stopped we're
going to be putting
all our support behind the football
association and uefa in terms of their
steps that they
may need to take but if they're not
successful in doing that
the culture secretary has been
absolutely clear that we won't hesitate
to take further steps
in order to ensure that this european
super league won't go ahead
well he wasn't clear though was he when
he's speaking yesterday oliver dowden
said the government will do whatever it
takes to stop the league well
what can the government actually do well
um oliver's uh dowden the culture
secretary set out a number of steps the
first step of that is actually working
with the fa
and uefa in order to find a solution
within the football family and obviously
that's the preferred option
and we would hope that these clubs step
back from the proposals that they have
put forward
uh if that's something that isn't going
to happen
um the culture secretary made it
absolutely clear in the house of commons
that
we'd look at every single option in
order to stop
this moving forward and we are
we're focusing on the initial stages and
supporting bfa
supporting uefa to stop this going ahead
but you cannot be
clearer the culture secretary couldn't
have been clearer
about the government's commitment to
ensure that this doesn't proceed
including the announcement of tracy
crouch
leading the fan-based review
yeah but with all due respect i mean
look a lot of football fans will be
pleased to hear you say what you've said
but it doesn't
it it still leaves that very big
question what in reality can the
government do yes you
you you've got the tracy crouch review
yes you're talking
to the fa and fans representatives today
but in actual solid terms
you know these these are ultimately
private businesses can you actually
intervene in any way well the government
of course can intervene and the
government has made it clear that we
would be willing to intervene if a
solution isn't being able to be found
between vfa and uefa well our first
initial efforts have got to be
supporting the fa and supporting uefa
to find a solution to this and make sure
that the
european super league doesn't go ahead
but if that
doesn't come about if we're not able to
stop it through those means
the government reserves its position in
order to take further action
in order to stop this european super
league it's just simply not right for
football
football is about bringing people
together it's about give me
interrupting you say the foreign
absolutely will take action
such as well the government reserves
this position to take any action that's
required including for
the need to take legislation the need to
take sanctions
in order to ensure that we uh protect
football interests in this country and
that's the right approach to do
but the the first most important step is
to ensure
that we put our full support behind the
football association who is equally
opposed to this and we saw
uh prince prince william voicing his
concerns uh last night about this and uh
the government
is right to be fully supporting the fa
in its opposition
and trying to find a solution to this
what we'd encourage
is all of these six clubs to step back
it's not in the spirit of football it's
not what the
um it's not what fans want you've heard
it it's not what players want is not
what managers want
it seems to be what the money men want
and that isn't what should be driving
football
okay so what sort of sanctions are
available to government
well a whole range of sanctions but as i
stated the first step is
to support vfa and support uefa uh in
order to be able to
give you i mean minister with the
greatest of respect and i apologize for
for interrupting
um you've said what the first steps are
we're clear on that you said there are
you know a range of sanctions available
again such as
i mean what realistically can you do
well the government is willing to sort
of review all aspects it's willing to be
able to look at
what further sanctions and impositions
that it can put on clubs
it could look at legislative options as
well but
we focus very much on the first stage
and the first step but in reserve
there is the option for the government
to take further action and of course
we have got the fan base review that uh
tracy crouch is going to be leading
there's going to be making sure that we
take the steps that are required
in order to be able to protect the
interests of fans
in football can we have a look at the
the covid situation
if you would obviously we had the news
yesterday that india's going on to the
red list
already what we think about 303 known
cases of the indian variant
in the uk which is a double mutation
which causes some concern
um have we left it too long to put india
on the red list and
and if not why are we leaving it till
four o'clock friday morning before
that actually happens well it's as you
all know it's standard practice to give
people a sort of short window in order
to be able to
uh manage their affairs it's the right
approach to do it's the approach that we
take them with other countries around
the world when they've gone on to the
red list
the government continuously reviews the
data
continues continuously reviews the
information that we're getting from the
scientific community
um in terms of what countries should be
entering
being put onto the red list and sadly
uh india has been one of those countries
that had to be added
i mean how concerned are you and your
colleagues and sage as far as you know
about that about the indian variant and
and the effectiveness of our vaccine
program against it
well we've seen an enormous success in
terms of our vaccine program
leading the world in the rolled out of
our vaccines whether that's be
oxford astrazeneca fisa vaccine
right across the country and it gives us
a level of protection that few and
other countries are able to sort of
rival
but we have to remain vigilant we have
to remain vigilant against new variants
that's why we've had to place uh india
on that red list
and it's the fact that we always take
these matters seriously that we've taken
the action
and the steps to place india onto that
red list
i mean there is some concern that the
the indian variant has
had a bit of a surge since schools
reopened that's according to
professor pagel from the sage group i
mean again we've got to
look very carefully at this we all seem
to have a mindset don't we that we are
on this real
path to easing things up and it would
seem
we've still got to be very careful well
as
we've seen when schools returned on the
8th of march we saw
children going back to school safely and
securely you saw
one of the largest mass testing programs
that we created
for school children right across the
country with tens of millions of tests
being
conducted making sure that children and
also ultimately their families
and the school and the community are
properly protected by having this mass
testing regime
and we haven't seen a spike despite some
people
um you know raising concerns that that
would be a the case
but that's because of responsible
attitude that children have shown
families have shown uh but also um
you know sort of teachers have led the
way in terms of ensuring
that children have been able to return
to school safely and i think it's
something that we're
very proud of that uh all children have
been back in school for
uh over a month now since uh the eighth
of march and been benefiting from being
back in school
um the prime minister is today expected
to to try to push our
our uh climate credentials even higher
is we think he's going to talk about
britain cutting carbon emissions by
78 compared to 1990 levels by
just 20 35 that is ramping things up
impressive in many respects and lots of
people are asking how can we actually
achieve that
well the prime minister has always been
clear that britain is going to be a
global leader
we were the first uh country to enshrine
in lower our commitment to getting to
net zero
uh we recognize that there's significant
challenges with that and there's going
to be significant investment and the
government's already
outlined significant investment that's
going into
um into our battle to ensure that we get
to net zero
but it's also about ensuring we have the
right skills in our economy
and that's why i'm incredibly proud
today to be able to announce the fact
that we're introducing
flexible apprenticeships we're going to
ensure that
uh young people and people of all ages
are able to
take part in an apprenticeship
especially in some sectors and
parts of the economy that maybe aren't
able to
usually be able to take on
apprenticeships such as the
creative industries such as construction
and including
new emerging environmental businesses
that are taking advantage of a new green
economy is making sure that uh you know
we
create the skills for uh to be able to
feed the jobs revolution that will come
out of this
uh you know commitment to generating uh
you know a green economy that's able to
service a net zero
uh country minister good to talk to you
this morning thank you
thank you for having me okay let's talk
to our political correspondent kate
mccann look
let's talk football because everyone's
talking football this morning
i mean gavin williamson determined that
the government
can take steps it's just not very clear
what those steps are
no we said to you legislation or
sanctions but it really is unclear what
that would be and i think
what you heard there from gavin
williamson was that the government's
first
method of trying to sort this problem
out if you like and that's the prime
minister's meeting today
is to hope that the football world
itself can do something to stop these
clubs from breaking
away now that looks like it could be
quite difficult there's been some
suggestion that maybe they could rely on
competition law
but competition or experts say actually
that's much harder than you think it is
so then you get down to what the
government could do itself well there's
some suggestion it could maybe
try and restrict visas so it could block
players from moving around it
might be able to impact the running of
games so maybe change the way policing
works
but all of those measures are quite
small and they all assume actually that
this super league is probably going to
happen
anyway that they won't be able to stop
it but they can just make it more
difficult make it more arduous for it to
carry on
and i think for those who are really
concerned about it they will say that
that's just not enough
okay okay thank you well leicester city
won the premier league
five years ago they're currently third
in the table but they're not invited to
the big table
of the super league let's talk to our
midlands correspondent becky johnson
who's in leicester for us this morning i
mean this epitomizes the problem
i guess third in the table but you know
not elite enough to to head off to the
super league if it happens
it does indeed less to having a great
season as you say third in the table
within touching distance of a champions
league place
but uh with the announcement of this
european super league what form will the
champions league
even take you know one of the things
that fans have always loved about the
premier league is the excitement because
teams have to earn their place in it and
any club be it one of the big ones or
the smaller ones the richer or the not
so rich can win
if they're good enough as leicester back
in 2006 and of course
there won't be that jeopardy with the
european super league the founder
members won't face
relegation and many fans including those
here in leicester fear it will lock
most clubs out of top flight european
football so there has been widespread
condemnation to the
to this side dear and adding his voice
to it has been david beckham of course
former england captain former manchester
united star
now owner of into miami and co-owner
of salford and he said on instagram as a
player
and now as an owner i know that our
sport is nothing without the fans we
need football to be
for everyone we need football to be fair
and we need
competitions based on merit unless we
protect these values the game we love
is in danger i think voicing the opinion
of many fans look we know
the other 14 premier league clubs will
be meeting this morning of course
representatives from here in leicester
will be on that call no one from those
six breakaway clubs will be there and
they'll be discussing
what role those six uh clubs could
continue to play if any in the premier
league
if they do go ahead and join the new esl
okay becky thank you let's just bring
you some breaking news this morning
on jobs on those unemployment figures
let's get our business correspondent
helen
smith to bring us all the very latest on
this helen m what have you got
so these are the latest uh employment
figures for the month up to the month of
march uh from the office for national
statistics and they show
reasonable steadiness in the
unemployment unemployment numbers in the
country
uh so from last month uh 56 000
fewer people are in payroll employed
jobs
in the uk uh that followed a couple of
months actually where that number went
up slightly so a slight dip in march
uh slightly different up to the
unemployment rate which is a slightly
different
measure of these things that's
fractionally down to four point nine
percent down from five percent
at what it was the month before but look
these numbers have been pretty steady in
the grand scheme
not moving a huge amount over the last
few months there's probably a few
reasons
for that the fact that we're still in
lockdown the furlough scheme
still continues there's not been a huge
amount of change
no dramatic impacts to kind of make
businesses very nervous
uh if you like but there are some
interesting details in here too we've
now got a year's worth of figures
and the office for national statistics
said for example that the highest drops
in employment were in sectors like
hospitality
the under-25s and also people who live
in london as well but of course
all potentially likely to change once
that furlough scheme comes to an end in
september
okay thank you well still to come
this morning at half past should
airlines be responsible for checking
passengers coronavirus paperwork we'll
talk to the immigration union
and the air transport association
the twenty two eight as many countries
face a big increase in covert cases i'll
talk to
dr david nabarro of the world health
organization
to ask what the next few weeks is likely
to bring
sky news understands the government is
set to announce a pledge to cut
carbon emissions by nearly 80 percent in
the next 14 years
we'll talk to the head of the national
grid to find out just how
that could happen that's at about four
to eight this morning
now crowds gathered outside the
courthouse in minneapolis overnight as
the jury in the trial of the former
police officer charged with the murder
of george
floyd began its deliberations during
closing arguments
prosecutors told them the suggestion mr
floyd's death was not caused by the
officer who knelt on his neck was
not common sense but rather nonsense
a warning that this report from sally
lockwood does include video of george
floyd struggling to breathe
shortly before his death
the eyes of the world are on minneapolis
the epicenter of protests
the courthouse but america is tense in
the knowledge
an acquittal could see an explosion of
unrest
around the country before the jury
retired to deliberate
both sides had a final shot at making
their case
was george floyd's death a murder
is going to go up on me man pull your
legs down okay okay
okay let me come with you i'm going in
please
here come on he had his struggles but he
shouldn't have died that day
argued the prosecution
george floyd said i can't breathe 27
times but derek chauvin kept his knee on
his neck
for nine and a half minutes the deadly
force used was not part of police
training they said
prosecutors telling the jury believe
your eyes
what you saw you saw it is not an excuse
for the shocking abuse that you saw with
your own
eyes and you can believe your own eyes
this case is exactly what you thought
when you saw it
first it's what you now know in your
heart
this wasn't policing this was murder
derek shoving removed his face mask as
his lawyer told the jury
any reasonable doubt should be a ruling
of not guilty
the defense argued george floyd resisted
arrest
and posed a threat to officers the
bystanders distracted derek chauvin
at the moment george floyd took his last
breath
that the former officer was just doing
his job
officer chauvin had no intent
to purposefully use or he did not
purposefully use unlawful force
it's it's these are officers doing their
job
in a highly stressful situation
according to their training according to
the policies of the minneapolis police
department
and it is
it's it's tragic the defense says many
factors killed mr floyd
including drugs his high blood pressure
that caused his heart to be enlarged
the prosecution had the final word
you were told for example
that mr floyd died
that mr floyd died because his heart was
too big
you heard that testimony and now having
seen all the evidence
haven't heard all the evidence you know
the truth and the truth of the matter is
that the reason george floyd is dead is
because mr sheldon's heart was too small
as america braces for the jury's verdict
the judge has already denied a defense
motion to seek a mistrial
the city flooded with security but a
sense of apprehension
across the country sally lockwood sky
news minneapolis
now restrictions are easing further in
wales this week where it's been
announced
that six people from different
households will be able to meet outdoors
from
this saturday pubs restaurants cafes and
other hospitality businesses
will also be allowed to open outdoors
from next monday
under plans announced by the first
minister more measures are due to be
announced
on friday
well across the uk the latest numbers
show 2960
new cases of coronavirus while four more
deaths have been reported that means the
total number of people who've died due
to the virus
is now 127 274.
another 83 225 people
had their first vaccine 221
193 got their second uh
that takes that particular total over 10
million and 43 million injections have
been given out in total
across the uk
mobile phone companies could be allowed
to build taller masts under government
plans to improve
5g connectivity in rural areas mass
could be up to 5 meters taller meaning
a maximum of 30 meters in most areas and
25 meters
in protected areas like national parks
major landslide has brought several
coastal homes to within a few meters of
a cliff edge in north wales
look at that the cliff fall about 40
meters wide has blocked the beach at
nefen's coastline in gwyneth
with thousands of tons of rock and soil
the public has been urged to avoid the
area
as a precaution look how close some of
those houses are on the edge
now police are looking for new leads to
track down the owners of more than 80
dogs
found at a traveler's site let's talk to
our correspondent
iva bennett who's got more for us these
dogs are not just looking for new homes
looking for their original homes
yeah that's right these dogs are found
during a police raid on a traveller's
site near ipswich
they found 83 in total all thought to be
stolen and police believe they could
have come from all over the country
but they say they face a tricky task
reuniting them with their owners because
even though a lot of pets these days are
microchipped many of these dogs here
are not and those that are aren't
registered properly so they've launched
this appeal to find the owners releasing
photos of some of the dogs as you can
see
there are various breeds various ages
too and anyone who is missing a dog
and believes uh one of these could be
theirs is being urged to contact suffolk
police with
proof of ownership vet records for
example or more photos of the dog
dog thefts we know have increased during
lockdown with demand for dogs driving up
their value
in this case following the raid six
people were arrested on
suspicion of conspiracy to steal as for
the dogs well
hopefully following this appeal they
will be on their way home
shortly hope so iva thank you so
if you think one of those is your dog
contact suffolk police
via email you need to do that by the
24th of may the email address
uh hopefully is going to be okay we got
it
on the strap no we haven't
uh there it is there it is i can't read
it from here
uh op scout at suffolk.pnn.police.uk
proof of ownership as i've i've said
that mind you
i think your dog could well be proof of
ownership when they see you again if
they've been away for you from you for
a little while good luck with that get
in touch with us as well uh
at sky stephen that's me um if you want
to tweet about that if you think one of
those dogs is yours we try and put you
in touch
now let's have a look at the weather for
you this morning isabel good morning it
was lovely yesterday wasn't it what have
we got today
yeah 18 degrees yesterday west london
very nice indeed stephen and today will
be probably as
warm across some parts of england and
wales but that's the last the warm days
really
as we see a front coming south let's
take a look at where it is at the moment
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so pretty decent day for much of england
and wales but this is the front that's
giving some rain i mean there really has
been
a pitiful amount of rain so far this
april but a little bit of rain on the
front that'll then track its way
southwards into central and then
southern parts through the next 24 hours
introducing some cooler air and more
widespread frosts again
as well uh this morning though yes it's
been a bit chilly out there but warming
up quickly in that rather strong
mid-april sunshine most places having a
fine day with temperatures up to about
16 to 18 degrees
the odd shower possible in east anglia
really small chance uh cloudier skies
for the north and west of england and
wales as the day goes on
uh where you have that thicker cloud
across southern scotland and northern
ireland there will be a bit of
precipitation but as i said quite patchy
and that will gradually track its way
into more central and then southern
areas as we head through tonight
and tomorrow with cooler air following
now that means that tomorrow you'll wake
up to a frost in scotland and northern
ireland but it'll be a fine
sunny day elsewhere frost free but
overcast with a little bit of rain or
some showers in the southwest
but as the day goes on i think the
sunshine will become more widespread
that'll take us into a frost on
wednesday night and a sunny thursday
now the government says it will do
whatever it takes to stop the proposed
new
european super league including
legislation
and sanctions the education secretary
gavin williamson told me in the last
hour
the proposals were unacceptable and
ignored the communities that football is
rooted in
this is a super league that must be
stopped because it's just simply not
fair it's not right
football is rooted in the communities
and clubs have grown up
in and um you know it's there for the
fans it's there to be
you know part of that community and this
super league looks as if it would
really destroy that but also the key
core element of football which is
competition
because as we uh watch for a premiership
it's not just a battle for the top
it's also a battle for survival at the
bottom and this
seems to have been dreamed up by money
men
as against something for football fans
now border force are urging the
government to make airlines
rather than immigration services check
passengers coronavirus paperwork to
reduce delays at airports
there are warnings that holidaymakers
may have to wait for more than
six hours when international travel
resumes
next month well let's talk to two people
who are gonna know a lot about this lucy
morrison of the immigration service
union and
simon mcnamara uk and ireland manager
for the international air transport
association
good to see you both this morning lucy
what are your main concerns at this
point
what's causing the hold ups at airports
and particularly at heathrow simply
because of the sheer volume
of traffic is the requirement that we
check 100
uh of arrivals and i'm not saying that
border falls staff shouldn't do that
but if airlines could help with that
particularly by ensuring when people
check in
that they've got all the documentation
and reminding them at the back of the
arrivals hall
to have that documentation ready it
already takes nearly twice as long
to check someone's details at the moment
just to check they've got
all the coronavirus compliant stuff if
they haven't got it have
done everything that they need to do and
have got those papers ready for us to
see
simon shouldn't that already be in place
from the airline side
it is yes and in fact some airlines are
already checking upstream because
if they deliver a passenger to the uk
without the appropriate paperwork they
actually face a 2 000 pound fine per
passenger so they're absolutely
motivated to do that and they are doing
that
um but one of the issues here is that
it's a hundred percent
manual checking at the border and that
that needs to change that needs to be
either moved back to spot checking
when international travel restarts on
17th of may
or we need to look to digitize and
automate the process because checking
bits of paper is is
with large volumes of passengers is just
going to result in even more
unacceptable queuing times
did you buy into that lucy either spot
checks or or digitizing i mean
is it is it the fact you're dealing with
paperwork that is slowing things down or
is it
the people who are turning up without
the right paperwork either to hand or
complete it
what we're seeing at the moment because
the reason we're doing 100 checks is
even if the airlines are checking
upstream it's not effective
and we are getting still significant
numbers who have only partially complied
it's quite rare these days to have
someone who's not done any of it at all
but there's quite a lot of bits of paper
it's a very disjointed system
and it's actually terri really quite
frequent that you've got
several people on any aircraft and
actually not all carriers are as good at
checking upstream
uh as we would like and you can get an
entire aircraft
that have failed to do one of those or
four bits of paper that they have to do
and completely uh with simon on the
issue of 100 checking
ideally we would go back to spot
checking it's no good for our members
either these queues put everybody in
danger put everybody at risk not just
from transmission but also the travelers
are really frustrated and
fairly so and they tend to take that out
on the staff and nobody comes to work to
be verbally or physically abused um
there needs to be a solution but is
there going to be something in place by
may 17th
i'm not certain that there is yes i
remember what's your you talk about
digitization
look i mean to people of my generation
that sounds like common sense the
question
the question is can it be done in time
do you think
well the government have committed in
the global travel task force that they
published last week to
to integrate the passenger locator form
that's the form that everyone has to
fill in before they arrive at the border
by the summer
but the dates they've committed to are
extremely vague and we want that done
by 17th of may and this is not beyond
the realms of possibility these are not
inter
you know incredibly complicated i.t
projects because
it already exists digitally but there's
also
industry-led solutions so uh iata has a
travel pass product that it's working on
with our with our airline members that
will that will allow either test
certificate or vaccine certificates to
be captured digitally and actually be
able to present those to the border
officials
so we're really anxious to work with
government on tools like that and
and we are finding it hard to get
through to them how industry can
actually help as well so that's
another key way is through tools like
the ir to travel past i mean you're
nodding away to all of that lucy i mean
you two seem to be very much
in a in agreement this morning i mean
you must have real concerns that come
the reopening of
of international travel for the vast
majority of us you know actually
not just the airlines actually with
extra work but i said
your members as well this could be
absolutely overwhelming
absolutely it could be digitizing the
passenger locator forms actually
relatively simple and there should be
quite right there should be no problem
doing that linking that into the
coronavirus pre-departure testing
and the booking for your home tests that
is more challenging
there almost certainly are industry
solutions out there and i completely
sympathize with the difficulties
of engaging with government there's
quite a lot of rules around
who you can give contracts to for that
sort of thing particularly at the moment
because that's very visible in other
elements
of coronavirus response but the sooner
we can get the e-gates open again
the sooner we can get a an assured level
of checking through
it's got to be more than just tick this
box to promise faithfully you've done a
pre-departure test
that's not good enough we we still see
thousands of fake pre-departure test
certificates
uh every week so there's got to be an
electronic means of verifying that that
is genuinely
a pre-departure test that it genuinely
meets the requirements that the uk
have there's quite a lot of sort of
niggles to this
yeah i'm really sorry we are running out
of time but it's really good to talk to
it's really good to talk to you both
this morning lucy and simon thank you
thank you now india is in the grip of a
health emergency with record numbers of
covert cases the country has now been
put on the uk's
red list that kicks off on friday and
visitors will therefore be banned from
entering britain now earlier the
education secretary told us
the government has to remain vigilant
against
new variants well let's talk to our
reporter neville lazarus who's in new
delhi for us this morning
i mean look clearly the situation at
neville is causing
huge levels of concern now
absolutely stephen it is one india is
is having the highest case daily
caseloads in the world
260 000 cases and 101
760 deaths were reported just yesterday
we've seen over the last two weeks over
two and a half million
new cases adding up to india's 15.3
million making it
the second worst country in the world
after the united states
and uh there is uh the second wave is
gripping this country
in in a strong in a stronghold where the
government
is really struggling but a lot is to do
with their
uh to what how the government has
reacted
particularly in the last few weeks and
months we've seen state elections where
even the prime minister
and his cabinet other leaders of
political parties have been holding
political rallies and roadshows
with hundreds of thousands of people in
attendance there's the religious
festival of the kumbh which is taking
place
uh this month in the whole period of
april where an estimate 50 million
people
are supposed to converge now these are
big super spreader events and
the new indian variant which is a a
double mutation is causing a massive
problem in this country
hey neville thank you so covert is
surging in many parts of the world the
uk
going against the trend with the number
of cases and deaths falling as you know
but some countries like india and brazil
are hitting those record levels well
let's talk to
the world health organization special
envoy and kovid19
dr david nabarro also chair of global
health
at imperial college london good to see
you this morning look
we listened to our reporter in new delhi
and a lot of people me included think
thank heavens that's not us
that's the wrong attitude isn't it
well uk had a really massive surge
actually just at the beginning of this
year
i don't know whether you remember but
there was a time when the
british incidents was the highest in
europe
now india is having a surge and so
too uh our nepal bangladesh pakistan
and also in latin america brazil and
i think what this shows me is that you
never know
when a surge is going to come but you
can be pretty sure that when there's a
lot of
movement among people then a surge is
more likely the only question is whether
the
number of people who've been immunized
is sufficient to make that surge much
less ferocious than it would otherwise
have been and that's the sort of issue
that
the chief medical officer and others
will be looking at in the uk
right now i mean there are concerns
aren't there i mean it's
it's ironic that the fact we are so far
through our vaccination program if
something like the
the india variant a double mutation
proves to be you know to be able to sort
of
not be overly affected by our vaccine
well
that leaves us almost wide open doesn't
it i mean
these are the concerns moving forward
stephen i i want to be uh clear with you
that i
personally expect that variants
will appear uh in different parts of the
world
that are capable of beating the
protection
offered by the current vaccines it's not
a case of
if but when and so i'm
saying to everybody that i work with we
do
have to maintain our respect for this
virus we can beat it but it means
maintaining the physical distance and
wearing masks and also being really good
about isolating
uh when we are told to i just heard the
item just now on the program
about the challenge of ensuring that
isolation is done properly
but that's really important for getting
ahead of this disease
and we're going to have to go on
treating it with respect uh
actually i'm afraid for quite a lot of
months to come yeah i mean
look the way you talk seems to be you're
gonna have to treat it with that respect
and maintain
some of these rules actually until until
globally it is being properly tackled
okay
that's it because although you believe
that if you put a sort of very strong
border control in
you can somehow keep out variants all
the experience over the years
is that yes you can slow down the
arrival of
new diseases through what you do at your
borders but you can never stop it
completely it's just
these viruses they conceal themselves
inside people's bodies
then they slip through so that's why i'm
saying uh just
we have to keep remembering this
pandemic hasn't gone away do you know
last week there were more cases during
the week
than ever before during the pandemic
according to my numbers
and that means this thing is still
ferocious
and uh we've still got to go on battling
it and we can do it you know people are
the solution we're not the problem
and we can get ahead of this virus uh
the health secretary talking this week
about a you know a third booster in the
autumn i mean that
from from what i'm reading from what
you're saying that that would seem to be
inevitable then
i think so the vaccines will have to go
on
being modified to keep track with the
virus which will continue to evolve
and that means we'll get new variants
cropping up we don't know when they'll
come as i said but they will come
and then uh because we're quite skilled
globally
at producing vaccines right now there'll
be a
really good response but just imagine
you're modifying your vaccine
at intervals at the same time you're
trying to immunize the world
it's a massive job and i think that from
my perspective
i just would like everybody to
understand we've still got a lot of work
to do
to get this pandemic in the box and to
shut the box and to feel
that we can actually get on with our
lives without worrying about it we've
got to keep the defenses up
yeah well dogs aren't about it's really
good to talk to you this morning thank
you thanks for the clarity
oh stephen thank you very much bye-bye
now as we were talking about earlier sky
news understands that the uk
plans to set some actually really tough
new targets to reduce emissions
the government is set to announce a
pledge to cut carbon emissions by
78 by 2035 so 14 years
compared to 1990 levels it's
really a big target how can we do it
well let's talk to the chief executive
of the national grid
john pettigrew really good to see you
this morning um
what do you make of this bold new target
do you think
it's achievable
i think it's it's really good news
actually that the government has set
a you know a significantly massive i
think ambition
of 78 reduction by 2035 and it is
achievable
um you know what we've seen over the
last uh 18 months i think
is a lot of alignment not just in the uk
but around the world around big
ambitious targets
what's needed now of course is we need
to bring everybody together
and get the right policies and the right
frameworks so the investment can be made
to deliver on these targets
and of course one of the things we're
doing today is launching our green light
signal
which is really about engaging the whole
of the country
and they can how they can contribute to
to net zero
and make their contribution really tell
yeah i i will talk about that in just a
moment but
where are we in terms of the sort of the
breakdown of uk
power usage in terms of how green we
actually are at the moment
you know one of the things that we found
actually in our research is people don't
realize that how much progress is being
made so if you look at 2020 for example
what some of our research showed that
most people think only about 10
by electricity comes from renewables but
actually in 2020
55 of all the electricity that we had in
the uk came from zero carbon generation
so if you compare that with just five
years ago for example so five years ago
about 25 percent of our electricity in
the uk came from coal
last year it was just 1.6 so there's
been huge progress actually over the
last five years
and that progress will continue uh
particularly now we've seen the
ambitious targets of the government
set yeah well in terms of getting the
public on board which is really
important in all this i think there's a
much more awareness now you've launched
this light bulb
i've got one here and of course it looks
just like a light bulb
but but how how does it work how do you
actually let people know
if the energy they're using is green or
not
yeah it's always giving the background
to why we're launching uh the green
light signal
but we did some consumer research and
what we found was that
we were looking to sell people how much
they understood what knowledge they had
about clean energy
in its role towards net zero what we
found was about 38
people felt a sense of hopelessness
actually that around climate change and
the reason for that was they didn't have
the information on the progress that's
been made
and the steps that are being taken and
also what we found was
that as a positive sign 70 of people
felt that they could
individually make a contribution and
actually more than half people said they
would feel really positive
if they had more information so the
campaign that we're launching today
with the light bulb is really about
raising awareness it's about giving
people data and information
so they can make informed choices so the
light bulb very simply you can
screw it into your desktop lamp and
when the carbon intensity of electricity
in the uk
is very low then actually it will come
on and it'll be green
and it will send you a message that
basically says it's a good time to use
electricity
rather than at other times the day
because actually it's the greenest time
of the day so
you know we're not expecting everybody
to go and buy a light bulb but
actually what it does it gives people
information so they can make informed
choices so they may decide to shift when
they use their washing machine for
example from one time of the day
to when the light bulb is green and the
carbon intensity is really low
oh that's really interesting then
because i've read all i read all the
bumps that came with it this morning i
didn't quite get that aspect of it i
have to be honest
so it is in effect a timer that says you
know if
you if you use your power now if you
turn the washing machine on or
as you say or or whatever then now is a
greener time to do it
yeah so if you look on average across
the the day in the uk so i think
typically today i think i've just had a
look actually on our website and
the carbon intensity today is around
about 270 grams
per kilowatt hour so 270 grams of carbon
emitted
every kilowatt hour the the light bulb
will indicate that in your region
if electricity is being produced by
green sources and actually the carbon
emitted is less than about 150 grams
then actually it's a good time to use it
so the light bulb will come on and just
encourage you to do something you know
change your behavior slightly
as i said move the time you use washing
machine
and if you look across the country
obviously we've got different generation
in different places
and therefore at different times of the
day it will be greener than other times
today so we're just encouraging people
to take some action and as i said our
research showed that people want to take
action they want to be part
of the journey to climate change it's
quite a big challenge and it's quite
hard for them to get their heads around
so
i think for all of us it's quite hard to
get our heads around so this is just an
opportunity for people to engage
and actually make informed choices yeah
it's quite interesting i
have to say john pettigrew good to talk
to you this morning thank you
thank you thank you just a reminder of
course we've got our daily climate show
every weekday you can see that half past
nine and uh half past six i should say
and then half past nine you can watch it
the other way around if you like
i don't require how you do it let's see
what the weather's going to do for you
today
is isabel
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
warm with plenty of sunshine across
england and wales temperatures probably
up to about the 16 to 18 celsius mark
doing quite well
cloud bubbling up a little bit but most
places here dry
whereas across the north well we've got
this front giving some extensive cloud
but just a little bit of rain for
northern ireland
central and southern scotland but the
north will see an improvement later
it'll turn chillier but also sonia to
end the day there